we got up to hear about sort of like the
years leading up to the to the chutes
and ladders web series because you know
I I hear a little bit of the urgency
they're worse liking our entire waiting
and I know for me what it was like kind
of like leading up to working on my
first feature but at the same time I
know you know I know from from seeing
your geek off that you had done and like
Star Wars like like fan films in the
past so so like how often have you been
in production prior to the initial web
series for chutes and ladders well I had
um definitely didn't in college that's
when i did my hips tacos fan film that
was in her before me criar um you know
did did did some shorts in college um
then took a kind of roundabout um
unplanned break um for a couple of years
and then when I got back into it um just
on it you know peeing on set a
production coordinator driver just you
know what any any little crew gig on
them um low-budget Indies and then
writing I mean primarily I started as a
writer a screenwriter who wanted to
direct and that's been kind of my my
growing path that is as a writer
transitioning to to a director um so
went the writing route and then did my
own short film um and after that after
that short film that's where I kind of
got that all that itch to get back on
set while waiting you know for script to
get produce or skip to get picked up
there's a lot of there's a lot of like
getting really excited and then
anything back for a while and getting
really excited and something's about to
happen and then it doesn't happen and
something's about to happen and it
doesn't happen um you know as everyone
knows there's a lot of hurry up and wait
and a lot of things that sound very
exciting one week and then disappear the
next um and so that's what led up to it
you know doing production in school um
just be non sets learning whatever I
could on sets and then and then do my
own short and I'm finally there's not a
point where just wanted to do something
else in and that's a led to it was
almost on passed between the short film
in the web series short from the web
series would have been a foreign for
nearly four years yeah for you yeah I
mean in that time he was like he said
there was a lot of like things that were
going to happen and then didn't happen
like you know I was with its with
everything worth you know things fall
through and each time you get a little
closer but each time it still still fell
through so it comes out to the same and
I think yeah I was a lot of it was a lot
of that for for a long time and and I
wasn't really a part of it then like I
mean I was there obviously like
supporting him and I have been about the
whole time um I mean even in even in
college when we didn't know that this is
where would we go at all but yeah I mean
I remember being 20 years old and like
with him in the editing room like doing
my homework and so it's in kind of its
its yeah I never would've imagined like
this is this is we'd be having this
conversation and so you know because
I've certainly noticed that during my
time in Los Angeles you know that
there's just something about being in
this area that somehow or another
whether b.a.p a job or like some kind of
like extra work thing you know this this
industry has a way of sort of pulling
people in nah you know I obviously you
have the whip list would be go but how
did you get pulled in by the do you
remember that
of being pulled i have a blog post about
the date yeah yeah it was just it was
one of those things where where you know
he wanted to do shoots and I wanted to
be supportive and do it with him and I'm
kind of a creative person in general
like my mom is really resourceful and
she kind of transfer that onto me and
there's a lot of like like oh that looks
really cool but i'm not spending that so
i'm just gonna make it so I've always
kind of had that ingenuity so it was a
natural fit when you know he he wanted
to do this and he wanted me to to do
makeup but honestly it was just like oh
like I'm girl are you sure and I didn't
really think anything of it but then you
know working full time at that time too
and like I didn't really like my job at
the time and I was really frustrated and
it was it was definitely for me a super
creative outlet and it was hard than too
because i was working monday through
friday you know 40 hours a week and then
on the weekend doing the film with stuff
have been right back at work and so like
we didn't have a weekend for like 10
weeks at all and and so and then i still
liked it after that it's like there's
something odd about this but yeah i
definitely felt that pole and i hadn't
decided like what i wanted to do because
i did a lot of different things like iso
and i do makeup and I paint and I you
know sometimes like put thoughts
together and different things like that
but I was like okay well what can I be
successful out like I if we're it since
our original plan was the web series and
then should try again afterwards and
continue that then what was I going to
be able to bring to the table to
continue that you know cuz if all I have
is my same skill set that I started with
that I'm not contributing in the way
that i want to so like I thought about
it and and how I'm going to be able to
get on to other peoples that's like
giving what I already have and then I
decided on makeup and it actually has
worked out really really well like i
have a shoot on november but yeah like
being able to do that and like Billy
know my kit and practicing and learning
and learning from other people and it's
been incredible to me I mean that's how
we've met a lot of people is from me
going and meeting them first and having
a good time and I mean that's how we got
her DP 2 or I've already worked with him
on a set before that I had done makeup
on from another set you know and it's
just and and for me like I I like
I don't I don't have any I mean I want
to keep you any teacher because I love
that but for me it's that creative
outlet and it's a great way to sort of
meet people and and you know contribute
and because because I have another job
that I'm also passionate about I have
the freedom to choose you know I don't
have to take a gig that I don't want to
I don't even have to do it when no one
so once a month or you know try some
month or whatever like I can do it
whenever I want and and just for the
experience and that is really has been
really fun and I only have to work with
people that I want to work with so ya
know me do you see violets progression
with this was this inevitable i think it
was and you know when when you're
working on low budget or no budget sets
you need you need a couple of MacGyver's
um if you're going to be successful you
need people who are jack or jill of all
trades and can do anything where you say
i have duct tape and this paper clip and
suddenly the set is dressed everyone's
in makeup and you know we've got a built
skeleton and that's what violet does and
it's like you said um you know where
your it when you're in that type of
environment in that grind you're either
going to love it or you hate it when you
find someone that loves it it's like a
drug when you do love it you just you
want to be in that constantly and that
was and that was violet in and you can
tell because it's it's not for everyone
but for the people that it is like you
just yeah and I think that's what's so
fun about like Indian per ticket and
indie filmmaking in particular is that
you do have to be resourceful you know
you can't just go and you can't throw
money at a problem you've got to figure
out how to do it and and I think that's
been what's been really fun and
rewarding about and trying to figure out
like how are you going to make this how
am I going to make this work um and yeah
i mean it's it's been I'm sort of
surprised by like the things that I'll
be able to come up with sometimes
they're like things that work but I
think you need that pressure of the time
crunch and the type of money deserve
push yourself and be like okay like how
how does this work but that's that's
been really fun you don't always get
that I mean
you know a lot of jobs like you just go
and just muddle through and and sort of
our no come on son now be resourceful
and violet is yeah she doesn't amazing
job you have to like appreciate the
stress and I I I like being stressed out
I guess is what it comes down to and I
had this conversation with my mom the
other day just I've seen a house like
I'm really stressed out I'm really
overwhelmed don't you like that school
well yeah I think that's the first time
I person would say that i enjoy i enjoy
be awesome like i enjoy it it's just
that it's like the natural state no if I
tits like if you're too relaxed if
you're just laksa days ago about it like
you need to be doing more look like
ettika it's probably not healthy but it
works for this
you